I came up with the title to this talk
and spent most of my time making the
photo slide look like How I Met Your
Mother which I have never seen anyway so
I've seen like half of an episode so you
know my name is Mara Eric
I am the tidy vers developer advocate at
our studio which we're not sure what
that means yes so how I found your
answer let's talk about that by reading
your code so that's all I have and all
right fine I crack myself up all right
so uh please know this is not the scale
something I was thinking of the other we
couldn't ID versus meeting and when
somebody put up a slide and Gabor was
like oh sorry I was just running that
code in my head and I was like oh like I
do all the time not at all I don't yeah
so when you have a question like here's
the universe of people who can help you
fix your code don't hear like people who
can run code in their head and all the
way over there is like people who will
answer your question without running the
code first and that's something that it
turns out like people who are new to
programming don't necessarily begin if
you don't believe me or think I know
anything because I'm not cool
even jenny/brian it's like caveat I did
not run your code people run your code
when you ask them a question because
they want to make sure it's right and I
kind of started talking about this stuff
about a year ago and this slide and the
one before is you know like first of all
this is actually true like that is I
have fielded a github issue that said it
doesn't work and also had our template
for an issue which is really helpful so
you've got a problem and it doesn't work
except no one's gonna be able to find
your answer based on that
like oh they're gonna need more
information but there's this newcomers
paradox right so like when you're new to
something you don't have the words
necessarily to just solve your problem
and then somebody's like oh like just do
fubar and fast and you're like I don't
know what that means and I ran question
mark foo and it's not even helping me in
the function reference so these past two
slides I've been that was also a joke
it's not a function so these two slides
of been thinking about for a while and
kind of between between then and now
what changed for me is that I've read
actually I looked at this yesterday
since I made this slide two weeks ago
it's now twenty nine point two thousand
questions on the our studio community so
it turns out there are or there a lot
there are a lot of things that you kind
of have to think about and you have to
tell somebody when you want an answer
that apparently not everyone knows and
that I didn't necessarily know um and
the thing is is that the context in
which you're asking your question
matters right so like different
environments have different norms also I
like Archer
so let's talk about like three different
areas in which you can ask for help all
of which are good like twitter is like
hashtag our stats like does this package
exist or like not like an in-depth
coding question or if you just want to
know like who might know about this go
for it um Stack Overflow is has a really
specific model that is incredibly
helpful but again it's really specific
so the goal of Stack Overflow right is
to have basically unique good
question-and-answer pairs on the
Internet and this was a flowchart that
it was in meta stackoverflow thing like
how do you respond to RTFM questions
which for those of you who don't know is
read the flippin manual and it's kind of
like can it be found with the simple
google search you know like but
basically there are like three outcomes
here like you can answer the question
you can improve it or you can close it
the thing is when you're a beginner you
don't always know exactly what your
question is to start out with and as
somebody who isn't a beginner you might
be able to help somebody but you don't
necessarily know the entire answer for a
self-contained that's like the goal of a
stack overflow question is that it be
self-contained heavy resources but you
might be able to you know put them in
the right direction so our studio
community has been around for about a
year
it uses a platform called discourse
which was made by Jeff Atwood who also
did Stack Overflow and it's a civilized
discussion for your community the
platform itself looks like this and it
lends itself to a different kind of
discussion certainly a lot of
question-and-answer but also these are a
bit more kind of freeform and there's I
spend a lot of time kind of helping
people to write a good question so that
they can get the answer and what I've
found in the past year or so of doing
that
it's actually really beneficial so
what's in it for me as in you so not me
if you're asking yourself this question
you're asking what's in it for me
um I'm recommending that you help people
answer questions which like feels kind
of mr. Miyagi getting his car waxed
don't worry I took out the Mike Tyson
slide but the thing that you end up
discovering is that like you end up
getting better at your own
troubleshooting skills by helping other
people rich is valuable and there's a
lot of advice on how to ask a question
this is from a paper that was published
in a year that I don't know ten simple
rules for getting help from online
scientific communities you don't have to
read this whole thing but number one is
like don't be afraid to ask a question
and like the subtext of two through ten
is like be slightly afraid about asking
your question granted like I am on the
other side of this like I it can be
really hard but you also have to have
like a certain amount of empathy for the
user so let's think I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you guys some good things about
asking questions and then some thoughts
I have on you know how do people help
people how to ask so it turns out
actually like the anatomy of doing this
isn't really unique to programming so
for a github mission we talked about
like alright the problem description the
expected behavior and a minimal
reproducible example and that is like
github saying that so it's official but
it turns out this is like basically the
anatomy of figuring [ __ ] out so like in
in my mom's a psychologist and like in
behavior therapy they call this the ABCs
you're looking at the antecedents the
behaviors and the consequences an
example of this that I found online that
I just love this kid which is like all
right whoa is the antecedent circle time
singing days of the week
your kicks other student consequence
timeout possible function escape circle
time singing days of the week kicks to
students like upward you like a linear
model I've got some guesses about what's
gonna but like the the point of writing
this I really got to respect the hell
out of that kid you know like the point
here is that like you're breaking down
an issue and it's easy to get caught up
in the technical elements of that being
like I don't understand this I don't
understand that
but really like think about the
information that you would need to like
open your car door or do another normal
human thing to sit through the days of
the week song and why were you trying to
do it this is like a huge thing that
people often forget to describe like oh
this is why I was trying to do this
thing when you say it doesn't work it's
very helpful if you say while you were
trying to do that thing
so you know like how does this work out
if we give people that Anatomy and does
it all go peachy-keen this is a very
real issue that was filed steps taken so
far I tried and tried and the thing is
they're not wrong you know like
technically speaking that's also not the
information that's gonna help me or
anyone find your answer like this quote
by Karl Popper like it's impossible to
be construct a way that you cannot be
misunderstood that question was probably
just asked to illustrate this quotation
turns out writing prose about code is
really hard and if you think about
what's going on here like dude over
there Chad like wrote some code now he's
thinking about it he thinks about he's
like this is what I just did and then he
writes a long thing describing what he
did like and then I had this for lunch
and my boss yelled at me and like I
wrote one of those squiggly dots and
like you're like oh and then like marna
my alter ego over here is like
interpreting that and I'm like oh it's a
squid on a semicolon is it a snake
whatever and then I'm writing an answer
backing code being like and then press
the third button to like if you think
about this from a computational
standpoint there's a lot of like
interpretation evaluation and then like
there's a lot of room for errors in
there so sometimes people are asking a
question this is kind of like this is
what it feels like you know like they're
asking me for a question I'm asking them
for more information saying like no I'm
withholding it look at me yeah I got but
the reality is it's really more like I
don't understand the question I won't
respond to it it's it's no one's being
withholding there's just only so much
you can do when you're given limited
information so enter magic of rap cracks
so it stands for reproducible example
and before I tell you what it is let me
tell you like the raison d'etre is help
me help you
I think I've seen a lot of people feel
like they're like everyone here is just
asking me to make up a practice I
already had a problem and now I have a
reference problem the reality is like it
is - it is to help us help you so what I
found when helping people this is like
the meta helpfulness is that like I go
with basically a three-pronged strategy
approach is like alright what I'm asking
you to do I'm asking you to make a
reproducible example why I'm asking you
to do it and how you can do the thing so
let's talk about the thing the keys to
rep excellence I meant a good
portmanteau so what you need is code
that actually runs code that doesn't
have to be run and code that can be
easily run which hence my intro song I
naturally thought of this to the tune of
rap God you guys should really hear mr.
boombastic heteroscedastic if that's
another talk yeah so like for reference
you need your packages you need your
object and I'm asking for this for the
flippin context I didn't actually mean
for that to rhyme as much as it did so
what's the point of doing all of this
well what rep X does is basically runs
our markdown render on your code if you
have everything there and then if I'm
reading your code like I can see your
error message I can see what code you're
in I can see what you're using and then
I can take it and run it myself and I
can help you which was what you were
aiming for I hope and I did not play
that gift before so now you can see that
in action
[Music]
even cooler in my humble opinion is the
fact that replicas also is amazing for
troubleshooting issues that involve
plotting because it automatically
literally this is on your clipboard you
cut and paste it in I can see everything
you did this issue was written by Klaus
Wilkie when we had an issue with the
line height and you can see he did a
very good job of keeping it minimal and
depending on where you're at in your our
journey you may be able to see like you
can see exactly what is happening there
and you don't need to do any of this
kind of like push and pull when I'm
answering a question
I'm not happily but like I try and leave
like a little bit of a treasure trail of
like how I found the information you
know so happily here saying like what
did I do I looked in the S book I went
to the our source mirror I found the
relevant part I saw the history and then
I sent an email the use of that is that
then next time somebody has a question
or the next time you have a question has
anyone else here had a question and then
read their own answer yeah I'm always
like who is that smart cookie or [ __ ]
and I'm like it was me yikes
so that's one thing that you're kind of
guiding people through this like it may
be it may feel obvious to you but if
you're a newcomer you don't know where
things are so or if you're yourself in a
year reading error messages um that was
something I did not do for a long time I
think I just read an error message as
being like super obnoxious and scary and
that I broke it and this one is an
excellent example of there being but
super useful information this literally
says like configuration failed because
this like this is what you have to do
but if you are in like error messages or
super scary mode you probably didn't
read it so what I end up doing sometimes
it's like her the error message which
sounds a little bit obnoxious but like
this might be that person's first time
ever seeing a useful error message like
I don't know if I don't know if you guys
have deleted your Fortran compilers by
accident but I sure have
and like the errors that you get are not
usually it's like again damn squiggly
marks keep circling back here to RTFM
like seriously guys read a book when you
write a package and write documentation
and all of that and you know where it is
it's really easy to feel this way I just
wrote this out and I have seen many
times like the response like it's in
writing or extensions well here's the
freaking manual oh just read that a step
away helpfully Collin Bay formatted all
of the our manuals as hook down which is
step in the right direction you could
say go read this slightly prettier
manual or you can really guide people
through the docs and that's this is
something that I try and do in part just
as a way of modeling like what is
helpful behavior being like here's where
I found a thing and some other things
and this kind of model of helping people
ask good questions to responding in a
certain way was something that there's a
great paper written called we don't do
that here or yeah and it was they did a
test pilot from Stack Overflow where
that essentially they had like a room
that helped people to ask better
questions and what the mentors help
people improve on was like you know
phrase your question title better being
like my boss is gonna kill me
SOS Oh mostly I don't even know what
your question is all I see is those
characters and that might be all you
literally see formatting so when coding
text or interspersed hard to read
community triage this is very legit like
if you're filing like I like I've been
working on this and this isn't going
that well on github probably not the
right place but being like here is the
right place
or like I do it on Twitter all the time
if somebody asked me a code question
like oh can you come ask me this on
community because I only have 280
characters to answer it and code doesn't
fit in there
framing the question and then like for
Stack Overflow like
fYI like kind of the culture of asking
is like we don't say like thank you or
you know like because that signal noise
but you've got a sense for that quick
tips I have like avoid a major data dump
like what I think I'm doing is being
like look look at all the packages and
manuals we have but they think I'm doing
is like great I should read everything
and I do try to use our trigger I mean I
do try to slowly guide people ultimately
to source code which you don't always
have to get to but in about a year of
reading a lot of source code I can tell
you there is really useful stuff in
there
and taking out bits and pieces and
showing people how you got to the point
where you could find their answer is a
really powerful thing there's part of
this that's about giving back excellent
piece of literature here thanklessly
maintaining open source software doing
it out of the goodness of your heart or
something but I am super into being
selfish because I think that is where
like the free and open source software a
happy place resides so I sometimes I'm
on Twitter and I tweet things and I
totally do that because those are the
things I'm reading and I want to be able
to keep track of them it turns out
that's been helpful for other people but
that's like a side benefit so I think
that answering questions and asking
questions are both really valuable and I
think that if you take an approach to it
where you're breaking things down you're
gonna be able to solve your own problems
better and you're gonna be able to help
other people solve their problems
everyone has kind of come up and talked
about amazing things today that I want
to go try out and I'm probably going to
break something while doing it and I
hope that somebody will help me out so
kind of try try and feed back into them
feed that back into the community so we
can all do more cool things because holy
[ __ ] you Peaks are about us that's it
[Applause]